hey how are you if you felt let me on
Twitter or Facebook or Instagram you
probably know what I'm doing and playing
backups - not right now because I took
time out of my busy gaming schedule it's
an acute video for you guys maybe I will
lure you over here with my like care
package of love oh you may be great like
you meet a UAV on this map most of you
already know that I was in the black ops
2 live-action trailer guys tweet me
every single time you see it which is
absolutely awesome but they sent me some
behind the scenes footage show was
so cool to see what the set looks like
how they go from this to this
Ming come on it's not every day you to
roll around on a blue screen with the
handgun and marine camera pans if I
couldn't do that every day
I would
[Music]
so much
the crap out of me no that was actually
for real because I was not reaction
[Music]
thanks for watching hope you enjoyed it
be sure to check out my gaming channel
because that's where I close all of my
gaming videos & last but not least if
you guys are playing black ops 2 and if
you want to be on my clan it's team high
J so I just do is go to call duty elite
go to the clan join team IJ and we will
hopefully do pretty well as long as you
guys have a better KD than I do I'm sure
that's not hard to see get back to
playing black ops 2 oh my god he knows
he knows what I'm up to
he's got all my tricks
[Music]